now you're a judge on so you think you
could dance yes so you were a fan of
this show when you were younger and now
you're on it is that awesome it's so
unreal i mean circle growing up like in
the dance world um
i was surrounded by so you think you can
dance i went to this was the season five
tour i believe
so i mean i've been around the show for
forever and now to be
a part of its comeback in this capacity
is just unreal that's so cool
dancing feels so good do you love
dancing oh my god
like you answer in unison
all the time
it's amazing i love it though it feels
so good my kids we have dance parties
all the time it just feels good it just
yeah it's it's fun because i left the
dance world for a long time
and then i finally got back in it when i
did dancing with the stars and it just
like felt so good
to do that and then actually like
regain some dance in my life and then
now to be a part of so you think it's
just it's unreal i love that for you i
love the full circle moment so what
perspective do you think you bring as a
judge for all of them
you know it's interesting so so my my
two co-judges with me are twitch who's
amazing and then matthew morris and
they're both like literally my brothers
now
um and you know twitch comes from the
the hip-hop the street background
matthew comes from the musical theater
broadway background and i come from like
the technical dance background and so
you know being being honest on somebody
and being hard on somebody if they can
be you know better in that capacity yeah
that's a different story than just being
straight up harsh i was good at that
john john legend he's so good at that
after he gets into i'm like how did you
figure out how did you do that i was
like yeah i was like because it wasn't
great and you did it all you worded it
it was like perfectly executed dismount
i was like what
[Music]
you